evolve doesn't like me hide this
team-focused shooter forces you to face
a grotesque monster in each and every
match and should you find it you can't
always flee here's the setup a
four-person team of hunters each touting
very specific talents is on the prowl
the quarry is a single creature with an
appetite for flesh not just the flesh of
the hunters but for anything that moves
by attacking the wildlife and chomping
down on its meet the monster evolves
through three stages of being each more
powerful than the last
clearly the hunters would rather tear
the monster down with the least
resistance possible so finding the
creature quickly and destroying it is a
good opening goal
Oh weren't that so easy should you join
a team of hunters you rely on a
particular squad mate to lead you to the
beasts that would be the trapper and
while you eventually unlock two other
trappers to choose from
evolve smartly taps Maggie as your
initial leader
Maggie makes for a good guide through
the ins and outs of pursuits because
she's not a lone ranger instead she
relies on her best friend Daisy an
animal called a trap jaw that follows
the monsters tracks and leads you to its
current location with or without Daisy
the hunting phase captures the essence
of a hunt it's tense simmering with a
possibility of a vicious monster attack
at any moment and like a real-life
hunting trip there might be stretches of
boredom a sneaky monster might Crouch to
hide its tracks or double back on its
own path thus leaving a confiding set of
paw prints even with a veteran crew
evolve occasionally tips onto the side
of boredom the good news is that hunts
don't usually hit the boredom breaking
point
there's wildlife to contend with for
starters though you'll ignore most of
the critters impossible yet you can't
always ignore them
either because killing one rewards you
with a temporary buff or because a not
actually a rock comes to life and starts
chomping on your tasty bits the world of
Scheer isn't hospitable though humans
certainly tried to tame
and then the big moment arrives in the
foreshadowed attack occurs battles are
fresh and exciting due to an in-game
conspiracy devised by involves many
variables there are the rising plateaus
that provide vantage points
there's the hunters vast dome which
traps the monster within its confines
and there's the hunters own weapons and
skills which damage and limit the
monster in various ways assault expert
Hyde uses toxic grenades the poison the
monster and help drive it to different
areas support class robot bucket drops
floating turrets that help the monster
with bullets and tracker Abe slows down
the target with stasis grenades these
battles are invariably intense there are
three monsters in total the ground
pounding Goliath the airborne Kraken and
the rate Master of the hit and run
the Lions battle is typically the most
straightforward the brute attacks
head-on throwing boulders and breathing
fire battle with the Kraken plays out
differently as this peculiar beast rises
above you and spits down lightning as
you can guess situational awareness wins
and losses matches as you become more
experienced you learn how to exploit
shears vertical spaces using a jetpack
to float to better locations and putting
obstacles between you and your
flesh-eating stalker there is no room
for a chest thumping Supercenter if
you'd rather be a lone damage dealer
then it's best just to play is the
monster playing as the monster is
deliciously evil particularly when
choosing the Wraith who can swoop in
grab a hunter and rush away depositing
the hunter somewhere else in the
vicinity monstering it up is just as
fulfilling as engaging in the hunt
though the pace is different you spend
the early minutes sniffing out the
wildlife and satiating your hunger which
not only reinforces your shield but also
brings you that much closer to evolving
smart play can yield victory if you go
up to the hunters stage 1 it's best to
avoid the confrontation until you're the
biggest bully you always knew you could
be just as good hunters are constantly
in motion so too is a good monster
the tempo changes considerably when you
abandon the core hunt mode and
experiment with other possibilities
there's nest mode for instance in which
the hunters must gun down a half-dozen
monster eggs ready to be hatched before
the monster annihilates the team monster
in turn can hatch an egg to spawn a
minion which tears through the jungle on
routes of a pack of hunters even at
stage one following a minion into a war
zone is incredibly tempting not only
does a duo do more damage but the
addition of another combatant can
confuse the team of hunters defend mode
meanwhile takes its cues from battle
arenas like League of Legends and dota
tasking hunters with shielding
generators while minions spawn onto the
map as specified intervals and go on the
attack its evolves most action-packed
mode and as such it's an appropriate end
for the game's evacuation mode which
combines five matches of varying types
into a single big match the winner of
each individual match gains a boon for
the next monster targeting turrets might
appear in various nooks for instance
evolve apparently rebalances matches
even as it adds these map gimmicks
so that winning the first match does not
initiate a five-match steamroll even so
it's hard to tell whether the
behind-the-scenes rebalancing properly
matches the gimmick it's profoundly
irritating to deal with those turrets as
a monster for instance because they
might gun down wandering wildlife not
only damaging you if you get too close
but complicating the simple act of
eating not every gameplay variant in
this mode feels as fair as the last
it's worth noting that evolve supports
BOTS which is an all too uncommon
feature and while the AI reveals its
imperfections as time goes on its strong
enough to make playing offline matches
rewarding on its own terms and BOTS will
fill in for disconnected teammates or
will leap into action should you not be
able to find a friend to take that
particular role whether with friends
strangers or AI though it's fun to focus
on evolves unique brand of greatness
suspense of the Hunts the exhilaration
of battle and the drive to dominate
you